this week on forward zach and i get
caught up on abraham lincoln
2024
what lies ahead how was high school
different back in the 80s and 90s zach
goes to the masters what we're watching
right now all of this this week on
forward
[Music]
and we are back it's andrew and zach the
zach and andrew show it's been a bit man
yes even though uh zach and i were
literally roommates on the road the
other day
i freaking showed up in uh miami and
then zach had to move over for me as i
took over
a bed in in our luxury swimming too
you took a red eye to you went to
bitcoin
conference in miami and you can't check
in no matter you've we've learned when
you arrive at seven in the morning some
place doesn't matter how vip you are
they will not let you check into your
room most of the time i felt so bad
because obviously if i'm there napping
then zack's like and i'm out of here i'm
going to go find a coffee shop so i felt
like i was evicting you i felt like a
bad reason i appreciate that but i was
fine man i was up early working but
we uh i think we both enjoyed bitcoin
miami yeah the lobby three dinner was
wonderful uh the conference itself was
fascinating i got to meet the baddest
man on the planet francis ingano and i
think you saw me geek out in a way that
i meet famous people periodically and
i'm generally like whatever but this is
like this is the baddest man on the
planet
andrew yang has fanboyed
there's two times i remember i'm sure
there might be one more but it's not
very often you've met very famous people
and you're just pretty much
whatever ho-hum shrug right but you
fanboyed twice one was what's his name
france what's that ghana so i don't know
how this guy was i just knew i mean but
this man is mad he's a monster his arm
is the size of my head yes
he dwarfs you and you're like six one
right he like he dwarfed me too i'm i'm
six four this guy big dude and just like
a tree truck just uh he's the best man
on the planet yes
his he's a ufc heavyweight champion and
he literally came out of the sand pits
of cameroon and then like snuck out of
the country several times was homeless
in france and then finds himself in an
mma gym and they like looked at him more
like we should probably try and train
you
that he ascends very quickly through the
ranks of professional fighting and
becomes a champ he's uh super nice guy
liked you um which was fun but yeah
andrew's fanboy and like kind of
giggling like oh my god the greatest
thing ever like you don't really get to
see that and then it reminded me the
only other time i thought i had saw it
was when
we were at npr
and uh
edward cullen was there robert said no
bobby pattinson but you we you didn't
get to meet him and it's my fault
because
i was trying to try and play cool we had
an event going on we walked out the room
was like robert pattinson was in there
and you're like oh my god robert
pattinson can i go say hello i think i
was like you like casted batman at that
point yeah he had no no he was just the
teeny bopper sort of no no no i think i
mean well he he
he'd established like indie cred yeah he
did um whatever the gangster movie was
or like there was a really it's like
running out of time or something
thank you our guy our producer james
good time
very cool movie and it was i think it
was one of his first like
post harry potter
as an actor really talented yeah i've
raved about him in batman but it was fun
to watch you fanboy man yeah so yeah
miami was a good time had a blast
meeting a lot of people met joe
jorgensen who was a libertarian
candidate for president
glenn greenwald
yeah i was named the legend was on that
panel certainly polarizing figure um so
we had we had uh we had a lot of fun and
now we're back
uh one thing i'm super excited about
this coming the day this comes out on
thursday also coming out
is
my forward unlocked book tour talks just
gonna be on free on youtube up until
this point you had to make a donation to
the ford party and thank you to everyone
who donated really really grateful but
if you didn't donate now you get it for
free you know
and i i can't wait for people to see it
it's you were there yeah i was there
it's um
i brought my girlfriend's parents yeah
holly's parents showed up
and they like have watched your stuff
and they're her dad who's like pretty
critical guy i was like
that was phenomenal he's just like
mumbled like that was incredible i've
never seen him laugh before um it was
one of your better better moments yeah
it's good it's really good yeah i really
enjoyed it it was maybe the 12th stop of
the book tour but evelyn was there you
were there a lot of friends and family
were there because it's in new york so
super proud of it super excited about it
yeah it's like 45 minutes that kind of
encapsulates what we're trying to build
here some of the problems we're trying
to solve some fun stories from the trail
so do check it out uh i guarantee it's
time well spent where do you find it is
on your website andrewyang.com
yeah if you go to andrewyang.com
there'll be a link there uh if you just
youtube andrew yang it'll pop up uh but
it's the forward tour live which you
know what that means zach no i need to
retire everything in that that it's like
it's like i'm a comedian who like the
comments especially came out and then
i'm like no
no old material everything new i'm going
to show up and just have to have a
completely different
set of stories different spiel that's
true it's tough being a comedian uh to
stay relevant that way you just keep
it's like an artist except you don't get
paid as much for the first hit album you
know well what's funny is i you know i
ran for president and uh you know i had
a pretty consistent riff and set of
themes uh which in some ways was the
spoken word version of the war on normal
people yeah uh and you would tweak
aspects of it and i would i will say to
our credit like i would tailor it
according to who i was talking to and
use that for sanity purposes if i recall
too yeah because i just want to say the
same [ __ ] over and over yeah um but then
with uh the forward
book and the forward tour
uh it's similar where i have like a
stump if you will
um and so that this is the stump uh
on youtube which means if i do show up
to your living room now i'll i'll
probably have to ask if people have seen
it and then i'll say something different
but but this does make me kind of happy
because uh one one of the the givens of
a politician's job is that you say the
same stuff over and over again um and if
you are a leader in an organization you
actually have to say the same stuff over
and over again quite often yeah you know
like and you think oh i've said it once
you were there so now i i move on but uh
most of the time you have to hammer a
point five six seven times
um and i for one will say like i i'd
like to
not uh just have to hammer the same
things over and over again yeah you used
to hate that i used to have an old boss
when i was on wall street he's like
because he would go around the country
he was it was in charge of like a tran i
was in transformation management he's
like alright get people these people to
do what we want
we gotta travel the country and just say
the same thing over and over
so that is a leadership and a management
tip is feel free to be redundant yes uh
because redundance pays yes generally
yes it's just about time
for your mental
awful for health health um or just just
your work sanity you know um yeah
so we got a lot going on in the world
man
[Music]
well uh one other
um
fun thing from this week so i
interviewed john avalon who actually
presented the fair vote award to me
um
this week which was also a blast uh and
fair vote if people don't don't know
it's an organization that is pushing for
voting reforms including
ranked choice voting my favorite thing
in the world that will help
uh reasonable people
they gave you an award for what just
because it's called the american
democracy award it's very happy it's now
on my bookshelf
for being someone who's been championing
a better version of american democracy
but i interviewed john avalon of cnn
about his book lincoln and the fight for
peace
um and we we're having a laugh about
this i sent a tweet that had two lines
in it it was
it was oh man it was lincoln won
uh
a four
person race in 1860 with 39.8 percent of
the vote and 1864
uh he named andrew johnson a democrat as
his running mate and you called it the
brand new republican ticket in 1860 yeah
which is accurate it was
yeah the republican party was formed you
know essentially immediately
beforehand maybe like a few years
beforehand five years beforehand and i
have not seen
twitter
blue check twitter in particular freak
out
to two statements of facts the way that
they have it was a pretty short tweet
[Laughter]
you have a take and then people get mad
or you say something
and people get upset or
that's usually what it is right um or a
journalist says something about you and
then right but this case you were just
saying a fact
i mean [ __ ] dude john legend replied
well john's a good dude and wasn't a
jerkbait he wasn't a jerk about it but
like there's a lot going on joey there's
a lot of people with check marks
replying and retweeting quote tweeting
so
why'd they i mean explain this to me
frankly well
why they get all pissy i i think it's
because somehow they thought it was like
uh
uh vouching for andrew johnson the
president which it obviously you know
it's not really wasn't yeah it's a bit
of a leap
it's a bit of a leap it was just two
facts being like look
we had a unity ticket we had a third
party candidate who won with 39.8
percent of the vote
uh which i thought were interesting
facts and frankly uh you know were
either new to me or i'd forgotten them
yeah you know maybe i i learned them a
million years ago many were like read a
book and you're tweeting this as you're
reading said book right yeah
and and the book goes into the immediate
aftermath uh to me it does heighten the
tragedy of lincoln's assassination
because
uh lincoln
um would have led reconstruction a very
different way in a much better way than
johnson did
um i i think to the extent that there is
an issue around it it is the fact that
uh people
are
are so divided that if you even suggest
something like a unity ticket there'll
be people that
dislike that idea in in various ways and
and what i said uh thereafter was like
look andrew johnson bad president
doesn't mean unity ticket bad idea you
know like
it might have been a good idea and
lincoln's defense too he didn't have
that many
uh
uh anti-secession democrats to choose
from at this point i think it might have
been a choice of one
i think andrew johnson might have been
the only democrat who wasn't got it uh
pro-secession and so lincoln was like
hey let's let's do this um and if you
look at andrew johnson's behavior at
that time it actually reminds you a bit
of trump where he's like
like very very uh you know obsessed with
grievances uh and uh
self-indulgent and uh like shows up to
speeches drunk which i'm not sure if
that's a trump thing but it was
apparently an andrew johnson thing yeah
so there are all of these these uh
things baked into the book and it's like
a fascinating narrative
but the overarching narrative is of
lincoln as this unifying figure who
tried to transcend politics at the time
there he had critics continuously
lambasting him and he was like yeah you
know we do the same thing in their
position uh he had very very clear
resolve on wanting to end slavery and
wanting to keep the country whole
but aside from that it was like look if
you're
you know if you disagree with me we're
still friends uh you know i still love
you uh and there were some people at the
time who like
bashed lincoln for that approach being
like no that's like
you know uh but there were folks in the
south too when lincoln was assassinated
who mourned and said the south just lost
their best friend do you
in reading the book talking to john and
now seeing the
twitter reaction are you seeing
yeah how similar
of a time a political environment
is it now compared to what lincoln was
dealing with i mean obviously social
media is different but in terms of just
our
honest aim on twitter crafting his
backwoods wisdom
no i i think that we're due for
reorientation politically uh the the
parties just feel so
desiccated and hollow and the republican
party got taken over by trump and there
are a lot of republicans who don't
recognize the party today and are just
like this is not
uh what what i
subscribe to or signed up for
democratic party
has a different set of issues that there
hasn't been like a demagogue takeover
but
you do have to look up and say the
democratic party has a
really really
let's say uphill climb for uh this fall
in november and if republicans take the
house uh and possibly the senate as is
projected you know one thing also that's
underrated is that in 2024
the field is very very
negative for democrats in terms of the
nature of the seats that are up for
re-election
so the odds of the democrats holding the
senate uh
through either 2022 or 2024 are really
really long
or or low
interesting uh so
that i mean that that's like a it's
going to be
a tough time in the environment
in large part because of inflation which
we're going to talk about right so if
you look at that as the backdrop you're
going to see i think a real
uh opening for some kind of political
realignment because there are a ton of
modern republicans who i think will be
looking for a home
there are going to be some democrats who
look up and say wait a minute whatever
we're doing right now is now working so
well because we're we're we're losing
um in various ways um
and i think there'll be a ton of energy
looking to coalesce around something
that could resemble a unity ticket or a
third party movement i was hanging out
with one of my good political consultant
friends i don't have a lot of those but
a few i really like and
always fun to do that because you get
what's the dc bubble establishment takes
on certain things um so a couple of and
also he's got new data like doing focus
groups all the time that sort of stuff
and he said uh focus groups are saying
that your swing voters that's what
usually they pull they're not pulling
the base that often are doing focus
groups with base that often they're
saying uh these swing voters don't hate
joe biden but they don't think things
are great they don't think he's
necessarily doing the best job um or
that um we're all thriving you know um
and i think you can i mean those if
you're paying close enough attention and
this is not obvious to like probably the
average voter or casual voter is that
biden has kept us out of war at least us
and or and call it high-end escalation
of what's going on in ukraine but
voters are kind of blaming him for that
right like and and all the things that
come with it let's call it well i think
yeah if any any voter looks up and they
just look at the the prices of the pump
every you freaking feels awful yeah
they're weak and just like uh you know
or price at the grocery store yep so we
hit today today we're recording this on
tuesday before our thursday episode
generally as usual
inflation hit a 40
year high four decade high
um
the white house is in there
let's call it spin zones what their job
is but saying that this is largely due
to russia and the russian ukraine
situation
inflation was really high before this
war so i don't think that's i think
that's it it's a spin zone situation um
so questions for you we've talked about
inflation a bit but what else did the
swing voters say
in the focus group well the other one
that he was saying was more than he
never um
noticed before was
usually he's like
it's tough to always put people in boxes
right but more he said now more than
ever you're finding people with like
just like a smorgasbord of of opinions
that you wouldn't be able to pick the
capture in in one bucket or the other
right where people are like super
anti-immigration
but also um
something that's more lefty on the other
they're more and also defund the police
like you're seeing like this kind of uh
more of a melting pot of views
um to the point where it's tough to
bucket them as
left or right um and it also depends a
lot on geography right so like some of
these is like relatively typical and
some of it's new so how these parties
work is like you figure out a lot of
what you do in focus groups figure out
who from the party can help you win
right so if we put biden in an ad saying
your name and saying pictures with you
and him or um
is that helpful or not uh and who would
be helpful if i put my democrat on fox
news is that helpful or not like things
like that they pull um and obviously
depends the state but biden is
there's not as much hateful rhetoric as
there is towards like a trump or so but
no one is it's not great for him right
now it's like this is you know maybe
people could so the candidates benefit
from having joe and after depends on the
candidate but uh it depends who they are
but not particularly no i think it's
going to be tough because you know
there's a limited tool kit around
inflation and the the democrats are
stuck messaging
uh trying to message it down but you
know you the price of the pump don't lie
the price of the grocery store online so
you're like look guys uh and uh that you
know they're going to punish the
party in power in that situation
every time ever yeah every time
there's a massive enthusiasm gap between
the parties right now i don't know if
you saw this it's a 17 point gap where
democratic voters are just not that
jazzed that that augur is very poorly
for them
when trump runs they they get excited is
that
well i mean this is right now so this is
going into 22. uh 17 point gap is very
very high uh it
would suggest a very very big swing of
uh of congressional seats
and you've seen uh some folks
frankly
uh taking that into account their
decision to either retire or um or
not run i mean there's been an unusual
number of retirements
oh boy
so i don't know i don't know what your
opinion is in this like
so i think
these cultural worlds wars are are awful
right now because
i think the right has a lot of the on
this end like some of the moral high
ground of like opening schools up or not
having our kids wear masks or
uh oh yeah and kovit's going to be you
know right and it covered kovac was a
winning issue for democrats uh up until
right you know several months ago and
now is not a winning issue but then the
other massive issue for democrats going
to be crime and public safety and
there's this terrible terrible shooting
in new york that just happened today
today that
uh so i will confess to you
uh i ran for mayor and there are times
when something terrible happens in new
york and i think how would i respond to
it yeah or is there anything that could
have been looked at a mayor what could a
mayor have done uh and on this one we
don't have a fact as to the nature of
the shooter uh hasn't been caught as of
this recording um but it it does strike
me that you know
in most situations if uh someone is
let's say you know planning something
heinous like this it'll be very
difficult to
to guarantee that that this sort of
thing doesn't happen if you're like
competent in law enforcement and you
just don't know yeah
those things are always tough to prevent
yeah
and so that this is part of the mood
that you just described the swing voters
have where they look up and um these
don't feel very good and so you know
like that there i saw an article by
derek thompson in the atlantic about why
people are sad you know and and there
are things a lot of people can relate to
it's like you're stressed out you're
isolated you're more likely to be um
drinking yeah uh
and so
you you look up and if that's the
national mood
um you're going to see
more
bad behavior um i think that will lend
itself to
uh
to crime rates really and we're seeing
that too yep so then when you're mayor
what can you do you can give an
impassioned speech about bringing
everybody together which nowadays will
not work and then three days later
someone else going to do something nasty
and then your your speech seems so then
you can ratchet up crime prevention
up to you know stop and frisk type
policies which have pros and cons and uh
the cons are pretty shitty i will see
what kind of decisions uh
he makes but you know there's part of me
it's like wow if i were in this boat you
know you're you end up
making choices that um you know like
whatever they are they're going to have
real trade-offs uh depending upon
people's hunger for
a sense of security
i think one ingredient in this is going
to be the use of technology where here
in the states we are averse to
uh frankly having like tons of cameras
everywhere and and surveilling folks the
uk has a cctv or whatever it's called
yeah there are other countries that have
gone um
more hog and light you know on that
um but i think that's going to be an
issue that that pops up more and more
here yeah what do you think of that i
don't it's i mean it's just the freedom
and safety argument right it just tells
all the time in some ways well you know
one of the things i was talking to an
author about is that i think that here
in the u.s our data is getting
uh
packaged and sold and resold by private
companies uh all the time and we trust
those companies more than we trust our
government right it's like if you say
hey uh the the city
uh or the state are surveilling you'd be
like oh [ __ ] no you know that's the
worst and then it's like hey
facebook and amazon and google have all
your data but yeah that's cool
okay google and facebook they're going
to make money off it yeah but then i get
free google maps and i get you know even
though by the way there's some really
negative effects of uh of these
companies oh it's pretty terrible yeah
but like you don't feel it as often but
the government feels like they can
arrest you for [ __ ] yeah yeah and i
think generally your trust level is
lower
um
which you're seeing these stories of
corruption come out i don't know if you
saw lieutenant governor got arrested
brian um benjamin benjamin got arrested
uh just got nominated i just got picked
by
yeah
uh campaign finance issues right yeah
they seem pretty serious yeah it did not
seem like uh
campaign buys in new york in particular
no joke they'll put you in jail
it's not the first time they put
something in jail for this so this is
the rough thing and that this is part of
it too is that the mistrust is so high
now and then people keep
uh proving themselves worthy of mistrust
in a way you know like one of the the
things around uh some kind of political
reorientation or reorganization
is that you look up and uh i would say
that
the republican party has had very very
significant corruption problems and you
can see that you know trump in
various ways um the democratic party are
there corruption problems the democratic
party 100 oh yeah sure for sure you know
and and so then if you end up arguing
against either of these then there are a
lot of people are willing to listen a
lot of people are increasingly checked
out
um
and the parties i think sense this and
so they're um they're trying to
retain
hold uh you know more and more by
pointing out it's like look you think
we're bad like look at these other guys
right right um
but it's
this this is going to to wind up coming
to a head in the
2004 cycle in particular
uh and
you know like it's going to
it's going to be a tough case because uh
and i and sometimes i feel because i'm
like friends with a lot of people in
these institutions where they're looking
up
and there are these forces that are in
some ways out of their control
uh
where let's say inflation would be one
yeah you know the one
major one are there things they could do
to ratchet down inflation the main thing
they could do to bring down inflation uh
would be to raise interest rates
in a significant way and then that would
have very very negative effects on
asset prices in the stock market so it's
a little bit of a
uh pick your poison situation yeah yeah
now there are so many parallels between
this situation joe biden and jimmy
carter in the late 70s
with their version of stagflation and
the poison they picked
was high interest rates uh and recession
essentially they had a guy named paul
volcker just turn that dial way up
i i don't think that
we have it in us to turn that dial way
up this time
[Music]
you predicted on the presidential
when you first started running and it's
in more unknown people is that we're
going to start if this
kind of
divide in the country and anger in the
countries continues you're going to
start seeing us arrest or assassinate
try to assassination attempts on our
leaders um and more
when your terms up you go to jail is
this
uh you know the arresting lieutenant
governor in in new york state
a beginning of that um oh no it doesn't
seem that that one i mean you know
they're all democrats here in new york
yeah that's true
yeah i mean
that that that would that's just not a
partisan one that's actual that's not
partisan but do you think that's um
something we start seeing i it's a
dynamic i wanted to avoid
um
but we we probably start trending in
that direction biden will probably not
run if trump doesn't run but if trump
runs he probably feels the need to run
as one of the few that can beat him yeah
that that's one thing i've heard too is
that joe feels he's the only one who can
defeat trump so if trump runs again and
joe runs against
do we all just collectively bang our
head against the wall if it's a trump
bot in two points well one of the jokes
i've been telling which is in the
uh forward book talk as well is that
their combined age in 2024 would be a
hundred fifty
nine yeah um it would like joe turns 82
in 2024 and trump be 77.
uh so i mean look at that
so if you were to run a third party
candidate who is under the age of 70 i
think that they do well
because 50 percent of americans don't
want either trump or joe to run i will
say if joe does run again at this point
you'd have to say his vp is going to be
de facto president during the term
because the odds of him uh just having
to step down in the middle of a second
term would be so high i mean 82 to 86
uh and
joe's a non-medical marvel you know i
mean like he's not like uh
he's like a normal dude that i mean he's
above average like you know he he's
functioning at a much higher level than
the average 79 year old right now
if it's kamala again and this would be a
tough thing because it'd be very
difficult for joe to be like hey it's
not kamala
um because you know she's your sitting
vp historic candidate woman of color
um
but if he runs with a commonly again
this time would be like okay we're
essentially voting for
that won't particularly do great um yeah
because you know trump will address that
does he think several politicians would
not say that the quiet part out loud but
trump will trump will say like this
man's too old losing his facilities
you're gonna have you're voting for
you're voting for kamala harris
so that this does rewind to uh does
trump run and does he win the republican
nomination and what would be the timing
of joe's decision can joe wait for the
republican process to play out before
deciding to run again probably not he
probably has to make the call when trump
is
declaring in my opinion trump probably
declares if he's gonna do this thing
sometime in 23
and then joe has to make a decision
around then to clear the field or not so
when did bloomberg declare
late 2019 right it's like november so
it'd be
twenty three before it'd be so he'd be
doing late 2023
and he missed
the ballots
in iowa new hampshire for sure but i
think he was
a few early i think it might be nevada
as well there's there's timing there's
like there's a if you wait too long you
just can't you just can't get on the
ballot i don't know if there are rules
on sitting presidents for presidential
primary if they're automatically on they
have to get on again i'm not sure well
the blocking tackling would be for every
other candidate is every other candidate
who's looking it's like hey am i running
is joe yes that's true and then and
everybody else has the rocky tackling
too yeah yeah and then joe would be like
hey i'm running and then no one runs
against him except for
uh you know maybe he's gonna have to
make a decision within the party if i'm
jamie harrison whoever running the dnc
which doesn't have any particularly real
power offense of jaime um but
they make that decision
after the midterms right you make that
call in december or december 2022 or
january 2023. yeah i keep telling people
to try and enjoy this year because uh
you know things get bad last after the
midterms technically uh yeah i suppose
down here but it was covered so tough to
enjoy um yeah so 22 is the year for
enjoyment everyone because 23 it takes
forward to this stuff again okay let's
talk about something more fun the
masters
all right i went to the masters
congratulations man thank you very cool
experience so those who don't know zack
is uh is it accurate to call you an avid
golfer no i'm awful at golf i just can
you be avid and awful yeah
i i like it it is fun um
it's a
very hard hard sport um and a little
pretentious on the high end but like i
like public course golf i think it's
pretty fun good way to be outside
sometimes drink some beers with friends
waxing balls around so i went to the mat
the masters is in augusta georgia and
it's like
if you've ever seen them putting on the
green jacket at the end that's the
masters and it's this escape was tiger
there of course tiger was there i saw
you see tiger i watched tiger with play
did you go up and high five him no i did
not uh they weren't really you're not
allowed to touch him so the masters has
very very strict rules no cell phones on
the course they have limited number of
tickets every year and everyone wants
one so if you are messing around or not
doing what they want they just boot you
and you never can come back and they
care less um
but
it's crazy um the merch in nice store
i'd say was like um
like a waspy black friday uh if you will
in terms of like the amount of so does
this mean that that because this is so
slight there's just some something down
but like did you aside from all the pro
golfers that you recognized were there
like a bunch of other luminaries there
because there are a number of
celebrities just walk around the place
it's a tough ticket to get so like nfl
players run around or a lot of nba
players are big golfers yeah yeah yeah
so who'd you see it'd be fun who did i
see 20 man you had a celebrity fighter i
don't know
i actually did not i saw
what did i say i saw a couple announcers
trying their names you know what it was
a lot of people like i recognize that
guy but i don't know their name that's
why um but it's because
i got such a high compliment the other
day in the airport what did you get me
someone saw me and i thought you were
they said hey that that that that guy's
a tv star is what they said there you go
your tv star and then i was like a
little bit oh you know what and then
actually someone called me uh daniel
davis which i took in the comments
because daniel's a really nice guy
and and you know in my view very
handsome
but it's like so i never saw a lot of
people be like oh i know who that person
is
and i um i mean i saw on twitter
afterwards if you like i think josh
allen was there for one day oh [ __ ] man
you could have freaking run up and gave
him i don't know if he was there sunday
but the other thing i've never been to a
pro golf event um
and it's a fascinating experience it's i
mean the masters is huge but there's
also a big golf course so everybody's
just spread out and basically
at the masters in a couple of places you
like plant your stuff it's so weird you
plant your chair
and then
you have to have a masters chair
um or you can bring your own but you
have to fit a certain size we usually
just buy the master's chair the
merchandise there is like relatively
cheap because they're
shelling out so much volume and the
place is doing plenty uh doing fine in
terms of revenue but you put your
business card in your chair
and then no one touches it it's just
like an accepted rule like you don't
steal people's stuff which is nice you
either mark a spot and then go follow
around a player and then come back to
your spot or
you go post up at a hole so we post it
up at 15 or 16
basically the front of the 16th hole so
there's a par 5 which is like a longer
hole in golf so you could see them
putting frankly for like what's called
an eagle this is uh
two under par what you're supposed to do
for those who don't follow golf or
putting roberto it's a hard like right
over water and then it's a short par
three so
on sunday a lot of them are going for
the hole in one because many of them are
out of contention
um no one got a whole one but anyway
it's crazy to watch golfers like these
greens are very challenging so you're
watching golfers struggle like i
struggle um but you know their course
much harder it was awesome man it really
was and then
like beers are five bucks sandwiches are
two bucks three bucks it's crazy how
cheap it is um then they do that
intentionally so i had a pimento cheese
sandwich so when you get a last-minute
call saying like hey uh okay can you
come to the masters last minute were you
like this is the greatest thing i'm like
dropping everything go yeah
so so everyone everyone knows that
that's the the thing it's like there's a
tough ticket
yeah it's pretty tough you can get my
brother does the lottery every year and
you can get like tickets to the practice
rounds like monday tuesday wednesday but
to get thursday through sunday where
they're actually competing
and this year in particular because
tiger i don't like so tiger woods uh his
most recent uh situation 17 months ago
gets in a car crash shatters his leg
they're not sure if he's gonna walk
again and then 17 months later maybe
it's like 15 months later he's showing
videos on instagram that he's golfing
and then 17 months later he's like i'm
competing in the masters and we're like
what and then the first round he was
like tied in 10th he was even minus one
he was like in contention and then he
kind of fell off as it went because it
was uh he was like we could see him limp
yeah it's hard uh so i don't think he
he's not obviously not the same right
now but
the the vibe it's a shorter course so
they're saying if tiger does break the
record for the most
major championships he'll have to do it
i think he needs four more you don't
quote me on that um but he'll probably
like the way he'll do is probably
through the masters he's got to win a
couple so now that you have this
experience are you like hey i gotta go
to more pro golf tournaments i don't
know or is it that probably or you
already went to the best one and now
you're like that's like one if you go to
the super bowl line
that's like so there's one that's like
kind of a party course
in scottsdale i think it's called the
waste management course
and
this there's like a you stadium around a
par three where like just a short hole
or people trying hole in one and it's
like chaos like people are just
screaming like there's no noise rules
and stuff like that so that looked kind
of fun
but
i can't say i'm a big golf guy i just
like it i know i've never been to a
pro golf event yeah that was my first
one which is a bit of a high bar at this
point
the masters on sunday is kind of yeah
well well done man you went straight to
the top i wore my golf socks today team
uh i imagine some people just don't care
about this but the masters are cool if
you ever get the chance to go to masters
or you can enter the lobby lottery they
do let people
uh a portion of the public
um so it's like people like whose
members who's in augusta it's like or
who's in like um you know members of
this course it's like
people from augusta and i've been there
for generations and then you know the
people who kind of run the world like
ceo of exxon or god knows what it's that
kind of
pretentiousness if you will but it is
beautiful
[Music]
have you been to the us open here in uh
in new york
have you gone or the u.s tennis opened
yeah it's cool here but it's like these
sports this is where i was like the
classiest sporting thing i've ever been
to and i feel like a golf tournament
would be you know a couple of notches so
that's what i'll say um i'm like i'm a
tall white guy and there's there's
certain sports it's tennis golf
i guess you could throw in like the
squashes and your other but they're like
old white people sports objectively
and
on one hand they're like they're old
like classic sports so they're usually
kind of fun to watch and there's a
beauty to them and arch them and there's
another element that's like feels kind
of douchey you know so my parents feel
guilty honestly god blessed my parents
but there was a moment where my mom was
like hey you should learn how to play
golf because it'll be really good for
you professionally yeah and i was like
mom i have zero interest in golf
and so then i went to a course a couple
of times at corporate events
and you know would take some hacks and
yeah guys sucked and like i never play
anything but at that point in my 20s i
was like i play basketball on weekends
on the courts like you know i i like
that this is my jam and like maybe when
the wheels fall off i'll like do
something else and to the extent that
there's like a sport for the aging
weekend warrior like for me it is tennis
but uh you know i appreciate the fact my
parents tried that because my mom was
always about me trying to you know do
anything and help me succeed
thank you mom i appreciate you even
though i ignored you on this one i also
ignored my mom when she was like hey
stay a lawyer i ignored my mom when she
was like hey don't run for president i
ignored my mom was like hey starting
these businesses might not be the best
idea
[Laughter]
love you mom
but yeah mom i'm doing the opposite away
i've been doing the opposite i'll tell
you another mom's story mom yang um so i
had a an ear piercing for
uh five years between the ages of like
15 and 20. and then when i took it out
did i know this yeah there's a photo of
you yeah there's a photo of me it's like
a gold hoop ring yeah and someone's here
left not just still a bit of a hole so
when i
uh took it out my mom was like thank god
you got rid of that and then i was like
i didn't even know you didn't like it
and she was like i hated it but but i
knew if i told you i hated keep it
probably keep it longer and i was like
oh my poor mom had to deal with that
you do that a whole bunch of times it's
like uh
i look back at photos of me and i'm like
mom why'd you let me
do my hair like that or look like that
she's like no i felt like if i got
involved you would have probably kept
doing it i it's got to be a thing for
dating too like it's particularly you
know like oh my
you know that the classic like
dad doesn't like the daughter's
boyfriend and uh let's lets her know and
then she dates him even longer you know
oh there's a good old days man a little
bit of adolescent rebellion to where
it's at i was living there i was a goody
goody i didn't do anything
i think i snuck out like twice and then
like doesn't mean it wasn't like
rebellious [ __ ] i did i mean you're an
actual rebel yeah you actually oh you
look you dressed like one you wore a
trench coat yes i did and i went to a
lot of rock concerts uh i did i was in
the like alternative uh you know music
scene so i did go into mosh pits a lot i
did stage dive occasionally it was like
going to the moment i was really skinny
so i'd go in there and just like throw
my body around and get thrown around how
old are you what is the age of your mosh
pit phase um like 15 to 21. into college
too yeah so when i was in high school
in high school i would go i went i went
to like the first and second and third
la la palooza oh wow yeah uh so then
like the first level plus if i remember
right it was like living color and
jane's addiction nine inch nails uh and
so you'd go and there was like you know
giant mud mosh pit and you'd just uh
get in there
yeah
you know just go and uh and
at the time you know it's like if you
fell from six feet up like it just
didn't seem to matter
uh
so
you know so i remember that
um i remember one time i was in like a
mosh pit and someone's like combat boot
like you know went into my face and i
ended up with like a
you know like bloody nose or some [ __ ]
but it wasn't that bad and just kind of
shrugged it off and kept going yeah i
was i was like oh that hurts then i look
around and be like oh you know what
happened i got like a bit of a bloody
nose or bloody lip um
i you know i was a bit of a jackass
during that time myself because that was
one of the joys of that period was that
you know like you get hit and you could
just like go and like shove someone back
and then they'd be like you know it's
just
like that was just
um
so was that rebellious sure
more than me man i in college too what
happened was i i showed up at at college
and then i would say to be like hey you
want to go to this like rock concert in
new york city and so like some people
would like visit me and then we'd go
come into the city and then see a show
and then you know like do some of the
stuff yeah i guess that was in my
teenage years
uh damn dude i did did i get in any
fight i got in a lot of fights as a kid
but that was like you know juvenile
stuff because i was like one of the
only asian kids so like someone would
call me you know [ __ ] or [ __ ] or
something i'd be like all right i guess
i have to fight you now and then i would
fight and generally lose no i was not so
i was very angry and because of the
anger i would
uh lift weights there was a period this
was not this was something it was
probably you know this is not cool but i
bought a butterfly knife uh in the city
just to stay ready and then i then i
brought it to school and then like my
friends were like yo man you can't have
that
you gotta have that knife in school and
so like i hear about that like kids
doing stupid chin and i'm like oh i did
stupid [ __ ] uh you know but it really
was until after columbine where they got
real strict across the country on
like any type of contraband like that i
mean i have no idea what would have
happened in my public school if they'd
caught like
like 13 year old me with a bunch i
remember very vividly like there was a
was that elementary school what was
columbine 99 yeah i mean i i was uh you
know in my mid-20s by then i was younger
so i was uh they were real strict it was
like that's uh
that was the time so so here's what i
would do i would come into the city and
then i'd buy weapons
and i'd go back
including my favorite this is not okay
behavior including throwing stars
and then
like ninja stars just hug them into
trees and try and get them to like say
they're racist
i'm sorry i'm sure it's not sure yeah no
throwing stars would be the thing i've
been canceled just just you know and so
we'd set up targets and these trees and
the throwing stars were not very sharps
they wouldn't work very well and you
just be like
like a dull metal object
[Laughter]
throw the vet
targets we'd put up okay
you know i i suppose like now it's true
this behavior doesn't sound very cool
but the the others have a good story
yeah i suppose
you know
you know i don't know though i will say
though despite my rebelliousness and the
music scene i was around people who did
a lot of drugs and like i would just
never touch it i was very very just like
no go yeah but dr alcohol underage uh i
think like one of the first times i
drank
i was definitely underage and then i was
like okay enough of that that's what
those things were
um like i never became like a you know
consistent drinker i drank once
and then was like well that sucked and
then stopped got it yeah honestly you
had more eventful childhood i was i was
a nerd i was the oldest but i was i was
a nerd well it's tough man looking at
this now is because like i do feel like
our culture now even some of the things
i just named there was this like you
know like adolescent stupidity now would
be like very very serious can i you know
like that that's true high school's so
different now man it's so different um
like the like i grew up and you
definitely grew up in this where it was
like the like the remnants of the
breakfast club were still very strong
until let's call it frankly social like
2010 like um where they were your
popular kids and your
nerdy kids and your gothic kids and your
ex like that and now it's much more of a
smorgasbord of uh participation trophy
like everybody's like it's like feigned
equality in some ways i don't know
enough about it but um there's a new
movie with rebel wilson coming out on
netflix where she was in uh basically
she was like cheerleader captain prom
queen
her junior year in 2002 goes into a coma
and then tries to go to high school 20
years later um and wakes up in 2022 and
she's funny i punch her pretty funny um
but like the concept is or the culture's
totally
just totally changed and that was like
one of the popular kids and it's like
everybody's popular yes yeah that's
exactly what it is uh and where the cool
kids stitch like we're all the cool kids
okay
um but yeah i was i mean i did like
musical theater and acappella and i did
some sports too so i was like kind of
mixed i was like a poor man zac efron if
you will but um that's that's a fun way
to characterize yourself yeah but he was
cooler i think uh i hung out with the
cheerleader i did not i hung out with
the goth kids in my school they were
actually some of the people that kind of
led on the musical some of the coolest
kids i met were goth kids like that
because they're usually
a better more more sure themselves at
least at a young age
[Music]
i i think this is something that
uh it harkens back to like a consistent
theme
i think
which is that uh when i was growing up
and so someone said something to me i
think it's a very powerful and
interesting message so it's going to be
up to gen x to fix big tech
because gen x remembers the time both
before and after
um so we're not digital natives where we
came of age before this stuff was
everywhere
we use it uh but now we're like okay i
can see the problems the excesses i
think that people who are young and
immersed in it like they don't remember
a time before and then the people that
came before us
you know aren't really native users in
the same way yes um and i thought that
was really interesting uh one of the
things i realized
uh gets me into trouble sometimes is
that you know it's like i grew up in an
environment where
uh you know
people talked a lot of trash and you're
just like haha and like whatever and
then now it's like if someone so i was
on an interview with this entrepreneur
which i appreciate it was funny
um
but he said to me afterwards he's like
andrew
uh you're a [ __ ] talker
uh you should talk more [ __ ] and then i
heard this and i was like he's right i
am a [ __ ] talker but like i'm a [ __ ]
talker because i came of age when [ __ ]
talking was like where everyone was a
[ __ ] talker it was a sign of endearment
kids do not understand this today but
unless you made fun of your friend for
his weight his race his ethnicity like
you're i'm some of your friends not
strangers oh yeah yeah you just talk
trash to each other yes um
you weren't real friends
and that's [ __ ] up especially today
but my friend showed me i was i got
lunch with a buddy of mine and i was in
a fraternity in college and he's like
there's a photo i was looking at and all
the comments would get everybody
canceled for because they're just like
[ __ ] on each other yeah that doesn't
mean what was said was okay
but it also means it doesn't have the
same evilness that it would today
knowing
what is now widely accepted if that
makes sense yeah totally it was like
part of it was that you like the
intention was not
uh to
like hurt or damage or not it was like
you know
like like you in some ways it was
actually like a sign of a relationship
yes correct and now it's different
obviously and because we've had these
moments right and that's
tougher for a younger generation to
understand for sure tougher for older
generations understand too because it's
um well beyond it you know and so there
are elements of it where you look at and
say okay like you know sure like
like trying not to say things that are
hurtful to people in certain levels it's
like yeah like what could be wrong with
that but but i do think there's a point
that bill maher made when i was on a
show a couple weeks ago he was like you
know but but then there's like actual
harm of like if you start merging the
two
then when there's like actual
violence or harm then you treat it in
the same way you you do like a
misstatement or whatnot yeah and then
like it and and so that there
uh you know you wind up in uh not a
great place because there should be like
a major major distinction between there
should be a major distinction between
chris rock making a joke
and will smith hit him in the face those
are two different things and one is way
worse and if you don't know which one's
way worse
i i'm gonna challenge you to understand
what that the physical violence is going
to be worse um
i'm not saying that chris is in the
right you know one of the tough things
is like i have a growing sense that
these distinctions are somewhat
generational
um now sometimes for sure no no
sometimes it's like you know i run into
a young person who sees things exactly
the same way that you and i are
discussing yeah so it's not like
everyone and then i hire immediately
be like hey let's work together
uh let me ask you this i'm watching um i
actually want to talk about shows before
we wrap this thing but i'm watching the
expanse right now which i've also heard
i don't want to this i don't like when
you're like the show's so amazing the
book's 20 times better i heard the book
is 20 times better so i actually want to
read the book but watching the expanse
uh which is a show that is now seven or
eight seasons deep on amazon it got
canceled after season three on sci-fi
and jeff bezos was like i like that show
and now it's um wow that must be an
interesting role to be in there i like
that show i'm gonna bring it back
expands very good um
and the concept is uh it's like you know
a thousand years in the future and we've
colonized mars
uh
earth is doing its own thing and then
they've also called it also
basically they find frozen asteroids in
the asteroid belt and bring the water
both to mars and earth for various
reasons so the asteroid belt is and
there's the space station along so
there's the belt as its own like
political entity and then martha mars
and earth
and
mars is like the future seekers right so
they're bad asses and they're like the
smart military the best military in the
universe that we know of and because
they're all there to grow and kick ass
and it's your risk takers and it's pure
like capitalism and like fight for mars
there's like that shared purpose and
earth is like bigger and stronger but
lazier and like no one really has jobs
on earth anymore because everything's
pretty much automated
um they fight their political infighting
all the time on earth
and
um
the question is as i watch it my opinion
is like there's a shared good
and shared vision that mars has they're
trying to colonize it it's not fully
there but they're trying to turn it into
what earth is
have we lost like you know definitely
and we talk about this bit on the pod
but like post world war two we had a
very clear and and obviously during the
wars we had very clear shared goals
national purpose yeah we've lost i think
we've lost that and the question i have
is it making us soft and um
because we're fighting over things that
like oh the grand scheme of things guys
does this really matter well this brings
us back to the lincoln-esque example
which is
at that point the country was being torn
apart by the question of slavery yeah
and then so you ask yourself today okay
it seems like we're more divided and
polarized than ever
uh what is it that's dividing us and
then when you try and find that issue
like doesn't come anywhere near like you
know the existence of slavery i mean you
look up and you say like what is it
someone said to me that these things do
run in cycles
uh that there's like a 70-year cycle
you have a couple of generations who
come and go
um and they don't haven't experienced
something before
um so i'm not sure if it's softness
uh i you know maybe something around
like uh
like
i it's going to be one of those don't
know what you've got till it's gone
situations i mean like i i do think that
we're teetering toward a version of that
in 24. i mean i worry like
i think
social media has affected our brains
like the number of
friends i have or young people i know
with
crippling mental health issues where
they need to be highly medicated or just
can't they can't function um whether
it's relationships or a job like and i
say that with empathy i say that like
that's hard i don't i think a lot of
them it's
um
not particularly i mean it's clearly not
their their fault or it's not nothing
they've
nothing they're doing that the rest of
us aren't doing it's just uh you're now
we've now set us up where like i i was
joke i feel like uh i've lived i wanna
say this right like one year of my
lifetime the number of inputs i've
received is probably as many as my
grandpa received in his entire lifetime
you know what i'm saying like the amount
of stimuli that hit you on a daily basis
i mean it's massive and
um there's studies on this i wrote about
this in my book like but the brain's
capacity to like navigate those stimuli
has not improved like a little bit but
not enough right someone says we still
got stone age brains yeah relatively
speaking right um
and we're getting better but not the
same speed as technology not even close
i mean what that's doing to us i don't
know but if you look at the numbers it's
clearly awful right um and i don't know
if we've
like we had a global war i was touching
the united states
well what what i don't know if you saw
one of these these facts around uh where
if what happened to ukraine happened
here like would you stay and fight i
don't know if you saw this
um i'm curious i imagine most would not
right
well it ended up being very very
different along party lines i think it
was like forty percent right right the
68 of republicans said yeah i'd stay and
fight
and then it was 40 of them
i would stay and fight which would
probably make i guess i mean
i don't know but i know a lot of people
would
carly would want me to run
i wonder i mean i'm sure that split
across gender lines is different too no
i'm not yeah i'm not sure that's true um
but yeah i mean boy christ has talked
about this a lot where it's the the call
to fighting is something that a lot of
men identify with
or have been told to identify with you
know and it's one of the struggles of
today and then you you just named it
which is like what is the national
purpose like what are we fighting yeah
what are we fighting for and that's the
other like what is what is worth
fighting for that besides you know let's
call it not twitter fights like what is
worth fighting for i mean i would say
some of the women's right stuff i think
is really really like you can even
ignore its impact on the individual
which we should not but if you did
economically it's worth fighting for
because in terms of
its impact on our entire society but
there's been you say climate change
right um but
um
i think like uh if you want like you
could break down some of the racial
inequality or wealth inequality from an
equal access standpoint these things i
think are really strong things to be
fighting for but some of the [ __ ] that
we're getting fights over man like
pretty marginal
yeah like when we're um
i don't know man well the worst part in
american life is when we have uh wars on
abstractions you know what i mean we got
a lot of those yeah i know if you ever
were an abstraction then it's like when
when did you win you know ted you're
just freaking out about big bird getting
vaccinated yeah like that kind of [ __ ]
you know i mean you can like let's say
the war on terror war on drugs oh yeah
like how the heck are you going to win
that war and then how do you know it's
like did you win the war on terror it's
like you can justify just about anything
and you've seen the meme or it's like
i'd like to congratulate drugs for
winning the war on drugs yeah with the
war on drugs
um no we did not win the war on drugs
yeah you don't want to declare war on
these abstractions you know it's like
that it's
well you do from a pr standpoint if
you're a politician oh yeah yeah it's
good it makes it seem like you're fine
the republicans have this they're
creating this war on families right now
um
and there's some things that there are
some truth to and some things that are
awful and overblown and this is one
reason why you know in my mind like
we're going to end up swinging in a
republican direction over this next
number of months is because uh we're at
a point now and i made this point in my
book
uh
uh is that like we're at a point now
where like openness and generosity are
gonna be a little just a little bit
harder to come by for people like
there's gonna be more of like a circle
the wagons hunker down yeah mentality
and and so if you have
a party that's making those appeals i
think that's gonna you know it's gonna
find a willing audience
you you know you say like your
uh
family your way of life's under threat
people look around and be like oh yeah
like you know let me do something about
that yep
this is um
[ __ ] man buckle up
um and you'll get a front row seat for
it here on forward um
yes
uh try to be objectives uh
you know so i i will
wrap us on something positive this fair
boat event i went to this week so
uplifting it was like this pro-democracy
pro-rank choice voting crew really
wonderful people a lot of
folks been working on these issues for
years and i i believe that they've been
way ahead of the curve
uh like i i think i might have caught up
to some of them and like now i'm trying
to get other people on board too right
um so do check out fair fairvote check
out the forward
book tour talk on youtube it's now free
and available if you enjoyed that then
do you know share with people um like i
tried to be both fun and engaging and
also informative uh and let me know if i
succeeded uh would love your feedback
that's a good point um last thing i'll
say
severance on apple tv
holy [ __ ] ben stiller directed it
dynamite
watch it i promise you i promise you you
will not regret this watch severance i
hear great things about severance
fantastic great things about the expanse
and i hear great things about uh
everything everywhere oh what's that
it's a movie
that came out uh that that's about the
multiverse but not in the marvel way
uh everything ever what's it on um it's
out in theaters like it's a movie yeah
all right
that's cool i'm watching um after life
with ricky gervais
it's a little sappy but it's good ricky
gervais i think it's hilarious i think
he's one of the best communities on the
planet i've been watching winning time
on nature oh is it good i really enjoyed
i'm a basketball guy so yeah you know
i've heard it's good yeah and i'm an
adam mckay guy too so yeah he's good but
will ferrell i guess got in a fight with
uh
somebody over because he wasn't cast in
that i don't know if you know it was a
really juicy role i mean i understand
why yeah
it's like that that role is freaking fun
but you know his friend got it we went
in
um
anyway we love you guys this time next
week i'm sure someone will be pissed off
on twitter about something we did so
until then
we love you all see you next week
you